well incredible scenes just in the last
few minutes we've seen the protest
leaders start to depart from the a
presidential palace and it's happening
right behind us they've been cheering
and yelling uh that the struggle has won
clear i mean you can see how empty it is
only
yesterday there were tens of thousands
of people
in this sort of grand room grand
stairway they were packing the
presidential palace
all here
for this once in a lifetime opportunity
to see this building and it's not the
only one so basically the protest
leaders have decided that enough is
enough and it is time to hand back these
government buildings so far three out of
four of them are being handed over as we
speak one more is under negotiation so
this is a really big development in
everything that's been going on in sri
lanka for the last few months this
building was occupied on saturday our
viewers might remember when we had tens
of thousands of sri lankans on the
streets they stormed into the building
they've held it since then
but now they're on their way out now
they've been upstairs cleaning it they
say that they want to hand it back in
good condition they've been putting the
furniture back into place sweeping the
floor
one of the reasons they said that now is
the time to hand it back is they were
concerned
about protecting it now they have been
trying to sort of be a guardians of the
building but things were getting out of
control because so many people were
thronging in here
and so they've decided that they've
handed it back and we'll see how this
fits into the political developments
over the next day